[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: I don't want to make
the assumption that everyone
knows what Reddit is.
I think most of this room will.
But I thought there was a
really great quote in your book
that kind of described it.
So I want to describe it
from the book that you wrote.
And then I want
to hear your take
on how you would
describe it to someone
who's never been to the site.
So the quote is, "Being
in love with someone
who has a constantly
expanding and mostly beautiful
multiple personality disorder."
CHRISTINE LAGORIO-CHAFKIN: Yes.
SPEAKER: How would
you describe Reddit?
CHRISTINE LAGORIO-CHAFKIN:
Well, in standard interviews,
for folks who actually
have no clue about Reddit,
I say, it's sort of a mirror
of the entire internet.
It's kind of a
bulletin board site
with everything under the sun.
It's got the day's news.
It's got every shiny meme.
It's got every conspiracy
theory, anything
you can imagine, you know?
SPEAKER: Yeah.
So let's dig into--
you're a full-time journalist.
When did you decide to take
on the challenge of a book?
CHRISTINE LAGORIO-CHAFKIN:
Well, so this
is kind of a funny
story, because I
took on the idea of
this book before it
was a good idea for a book.
I mean, it was back in 2011.
And I was a young journalist
working at "Inc." magazine.
And I met with Alexis
Ohanian and Steve Hoffman
on a total whim at
South by Southwest.
And they were, at
the time, working
on a site called Hipmunk,
which is a travel search
site like Kayak, only
it searches sites
based on the agony they
would induce on the user
rather than, say, price.
And I wasn't that interested
in their little travel site.
I was interested in the fact
that these two seemingly normal
guys built Reddit, which, at
the time, was in the news for--
I think it was--
I can't remember if it was
either jailbait or creep
shots or a combination of both.
But it also was sort
of known already
as the internet's
virality engine.
It was something that,
when one of our articles--
as a journalist,
when an article would
reach the front page of Reddit
or even the top of a news
subreddit or something, it
would send so much traffic.
We called it the
Reddit hug of death
that it would
cripple our servers,
but, you know, give
so much traffic.
So I wanted to know
more about Reddit.
And I didn't get to know
that day, all the stories.
But turns out, Alexis Ohanian
lived in Brooklyn, as did I.
And we were able to meet
up on Atlantic Avenue,
have some coffee.
So I heard the whole story and
thought, this is fantastic.
Just what they went through
in the first year of building
it alone was such a
scrappy, great, garage
building-a-startup story
that I pitched them both.
I pitched Steve and Alexis
on exclusively talking to me
for the purpose of a book.
And so it's been years,
years in the making.
SPEAKER: So you
kind of met halfway
through where it is today.
CHRISTINE
LAGORIO-CHAFKIN: Oh, yeah.
And none of the crazy recent
stuff had happened yet.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
And you're at a place that it's
also a start-in-a-garage kind
of really interesting start.
So when you started to
uncover the history of Reddit,
you started digging
into the book,
what was that look-back
to that first,
kind of, beginning years
of how this site spawned
into what it is today?
CHRISTINE
LAGORIO-CHAFKIN: Right.
Well, those are kind of the
nice, friendly, gentle times.
And it was fascinating to look
back because you see the seeds
of how virality works and how
things-- just little ideas--
can take off online in ways
that we had never seen before.
So I mean, from one of--
Reddit has two magic
secret sauces, right?
They're not even secret.
But there's the algorithm
that powers the front page
and everything on the
site, from every comment
and how the threads
are threaded,
to just how stuff
bubbles to the front page
and how much time it is
allotted to stay there.
Then, that's coupled with
the fact that moderators--
well, basically anyone on the
planet can start a subreddit.
But then, you have to
take on the responsibility
of running that thing.
You are responsible
for its content
and for maintaining the rules of
that little fraction of Reddit.
So having thousands
upon thousands
of volunteer moderators paired
with that algorithm, I think,
is what made Reddit so special.
And then it allowed us to
see, in the early days, things
like--
there was this great story
called Mr. Splashy Pants.
Are any of you guys familiar
with Mr. Splashy Pants?
OK.
If you've heard
Alexis speak, you've
heard this story, probably,
because he loves to tell it.
But it really was one
of the first moments
where you could see, OK, this
formula on Reddit is working.
And when something
becomes popular on Reddit,
its ready for mainstream
viewing by everyone else.
What had happened was
Greenpeace decided
to-- they were trying
to just basically build
some community online
around whale support
and earn money for tracking
more whales avoiding
Japanese harpooning.
And they decided to open up
a contest for the internet,
in general, to name a whale.
And there were beautiful names
that people had submitted.
I think one was
Kaimana, which means--
I forget exactly.
It means something.
It means, like, lovely
creature of the sea.
And someone posted
to Reddit, hey,
Greenpeace is doing this
campaign to name a whale.
Let's name him
Mr. Splashy Pants.
Go to the site and vote
up Mr. Splashy Pants.
So of course,
redditors did en masse.
So did people from 4chan.
So did lots of folks.
And Greenpeace was
not happy about this.
But Mr. Splashy Pants did win.
And then for a while, Greenpeace
had a really good merch
business on its
hands with that one.
SPEAKER: So we'll get into some
of the virality of the site
and some of good and
bad that comes with it.
But looking back at,
from where it started
to where it is today, what was
the part of the history that
surprised you most?
CHRISTINE LAGORIO-CHAFKIN: Well,
I mean, the business story.
I'm a business journalist.
The story of Reddit sustaining
itself through the years
was just consistently the most
surprising and fascinating
story to me.
I think that's one that's
little known, as well.
So Reddit was acquired
just more than a year
after it was created.
It was acquired by Condé Nast
whose parent company is Advance
Publications.
They're known for their
shiny, glossy magazines.
Now, Reddit is not that.
But it was acquired for a
little more than $10 million.
And after that point, Reddit
was put into the "Wired" office
in San Francisco.
The guys moved out there.
There's four to six of them at
a time in a little conference
room in "Wired."
And they were sort of left to
build the site on their own.
And miraculously, that worked.
The Newhouse family that runs
Condé was pretty hands-off with
them.
They had quarterly
meetings and shared goals
and that sort of thing.
But otherwise, it was just
left to its own devices.
And somehow, it worked.
When Steve and Alexis, the
two founders, left Reddit,
it worked.
There was amazing growth in
the year after they left.
When Condé Nast spun out
Reddit from Condé into Advance
Publications, basically allowing
it to operate like a Silicon
Valley company
and take VC money,
which it subsequently
did, that still worked.
They got a new CEO.
They just put in a total
outsider named Yishan Wong.
And the site kept growing
and growing and growing,
and even operating under a
different business model.
So watching that unfold, I
think, it was just incredible.
And Yishan made some very
bizarre business decisions
during his tenure.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
That was going to
be my next question.
So when Alexis and
Steve left, there
was a period where
he was in charge.
And there's a lot in the book.
And the book goes into
the history of everything,
so I highly recommend it.
What were some of
those decisions
that they had to turn back
that you kind of uncovered?
And now, with looking
at where they are today,
how that section of the business
really took it to, again,
where they are today?
CHRISTINE LAGORIO-CHAFKIN: Yeah.
Well, I think the
funniest one is actually
before Yishan came
in, when the guys were
unable to hire anyone.
There were four guys just
basically working on Reddit.
And they wanted anyone.
They wanted just
another programmer.
And Condé Nast told them, well,
if you bump up your revenue,
make $1 million for us next
year, you can hire someone.
And they were just looking
at each other like, what?
And so instead of just
shuffling their feet,
they decided to wait for a
summer Friday when they assumed
that most Condé executives
would be off in the Hamptons.
And they launched a thing
called Reddit Gold, which
basically allowed people
to give them donations.
It was sort of a
subscription model.
But there wasn't-- they
didn't really offer anything
in exchange for the money yet.
And they turned the thing on.
And nobody at Condé was pissed
because they didn't notice
at first.
But by Monday, they had raised
so much money that no one
at Condé was upset.
So it actually worked.
And I mean, I--
a funny-- a little
known fact about this--
Steve Hoffman, who's
the CEO of Reddit now,
was not at Reddit at the time.
And he told me later,
much, much later,
when I was asking
him about this--
he said he was
watching from afar.
And he thought it was a
little embarrassing that they
had stooped to this level.
These guys were all his friends.
But they turned on Reddit Gold.
And I said, well,
it worked though.
And he looked at me and said,
well, it didn't not work.
SPEAKER: So that's
an interesting piece.
A lot of when you read
the book, you realize
that it doesn't
seem like everything
was always very
well thought out.
It was more of a-- they
kind of had to just roll
with what happened.
CHRISTINE
LAGORIO-CHAFKIN: Right.
Yeah.
SPEAKER: How do you
think that-- again,
how does that shape where
we are today in the business
side of the history?
CHRISTINE LAGORIO-CHAFKIN:
Well, I actually think more
interesting than the business
side of the history is--
and I can get to that too-- but
is the social side of things.
How did it shape
internet culture today?
And how did it shape
what Reddit became?
I mean, you think
about how Reddit
was founded as sort
of this freedom
from the press, a place
where users have the power
to upvote and downvote
things and determine
what's on the top of every home
page rather than an editor.
That, sort of, was
taken to its extreme
by this community, which
was left to its own devices
during those years.
And users on the site loved to
push and prod at those limits.
What was the limit
of free speech?
What is the limit of
what we can get away
with in terms of gore and
anything-- pornography,
and animal abuse,
like, a highway crash?
It's like, what's the
limit of what's allowed?
And that's why,
during those years,
the community spiraled
out of control at times.
On the business
side, I would say,
Reddit's kind of been in debt
to itself for years, right?
As soon as--
Steve Huffman came
back more than,
I guess, three years ago as CEO.
And he still has his work
cut out for him, right?
The site had taken $50 million
in venture capital at that time
and now has taken
a great deal more.
But he had to hire
up from something
like 20-some people, after a
bunch left after he returned,
to the more than
400 it has today.
And that's before you
even start working
on those noxious content issues
and building in really reliable
advertising to the site.
SPEAKER: So I want
to pivot a little bit
to another player
besides-- obviously,
Alexis and Steve
are the main two.
CHRISTINE LAGORIO-CHAFKIN: Yeah.
SPEAKER: There's one who kind
of weaves their way in and out
of this book a lot,
almost to the point
where you got to remember
it's not fiction--
is Aaron Swartz.
So what was his role early on?
And then obviously, he
kind of had a sad ending
with suicide towards the
end of his time with Reddit.
It's a big part of his story.
So what was it like hearing
people talk about his time
at the company?
CHRISTINE LAGORIO-CHAFKIN:
I have to say,
as a reporter, that was one of
the most interesting threads
to pull, and then, as a
writer, one of the most
complicated stories to tell.
One of the great things
about writing this book
was that every person in it
is a super complex character.
Nobody is as they seem on
the surface at first, right?
Because you've got
Alexis Ohanian,
who's a great showman
and a charismatic dude.
But he's gone through some
really troubling times
personally.
And then you've got
Aaron Swartz, who--
I always held him up as sort of
this early internet wunderkind.
He was this great
hacker with a heart.
And he obviously
had a tragic end.
And I thought this was
a fascinating story.
But then I started to hear
about the early days at Reddit.
When he was just 19
years old, he basically
stumbled into
working for Reddit.
Paul Graham, who
started Y Combinator,
suggested that he started
working with those guys
because his own startup
sort of floundered.
And he did.
And he and Steve rewrote
the site into Python.
And then, after that, I
started hearing that he just
sort of gradually
stopped working on Reddit
and started writing
a book on childhood
development in his room.
And this all--
their relationship
got really fractured.
And I thought, god, this
is such a tricky story
to write because he's
someone so beloved.
And then to hear that--
I heard from many sources that
he was one of the reasons that
they sold the company so
early, is they couldn't--
they all couldn't
work together anymore.
And then Aaron left shortly
after the acquisition.
It was sort of amazing
that he even stuck around
that long, I learned.
And I do think he loved Reddit.
I do think that part of
Reddit's original spirit--
and it's sustaining.
Its spirit to this day was sort
of that hacker with a glint
in his eye, that trouble-maker,
information-wants-to-be-free
sort of activist
behind a screen.
And you can see a
little bit of his sense
of humor and his
passion still in the way
the site thinks today.
Similarly, you can see Steve
Huffman's sense of humor
in the site--
that trollish, nothing is
as it seems on the surface--
that's Steve, for sure.
SPEAKER: So you mentioned
the complex characters.
As you interviewed a lot of
different people for this book,
how did you piece
together what you
would hear from the person
versus what you're hearing
from somebody else
explaining, sometimes
the same story, but hearing
very different things,
to kind of piece together
what was the reality?
CHRISTINE LAGORIO-CHAFKIN:
Well, as a journalist,
there are certain layers of
how deep you can go, right?
If I'm just working on a
daily news story or something,
I just take what is said and
what is facts at, kind of,
face value.
When you're working on
a narrative like this,
it's so much deeper
because you have
to try to get as
many perspectives
on a situation as possible.
There are certain scenes
from the book that I was not
present at, that read
like I was present at,
because I've spoken
to so many people
about that moment in time.
There are others, by the way,
that I was not present at,
that I simply could put together
from a photograph or a video
or something.
It's amazing.
This is a book
about the internet.
And the internet is just
riches of documentation.
The research was so
fun and so interesting
at times because I could
see a photo from a day
and put it together with
what people had told me
and read someone's
blog post about it
and check out the Reddit
threads from that moment as well
and then piece
everything together.
That said, not every
source agrees with itself.
There were certain facts
that one person would just
disagree with.
And because I was
reporting on things
at times that happened
12 years ago--
memories are all different.
I learned so much about how the
human brain and memories work.
Everyone is so
different in terms
of how they process information
and which pieces they retain.
So I really had to
weigh heavily on people
whose memories were kind of
trust-- were lined up at times.
And then I knew that their
other ones would line up as well
or I could weigh a
little more heavily.
Or I could lean on
them more heavily.
SPEAKER: So I want to
switch gears a little bit
to the social aspects
that you mentioned.
CHRISTINE LAGORIO-CHAFKIN: Sure.
SPEAKER: Reddit's obviously--
has a very interesting social
aspect of it--
some good, some bad.
I want to get into a couple
that you cover in the book--
some good, some bad.
Which would you prefer
to go first, good or bad?
CHRISTINE LAGORIO-CHAFKIN:
Oh, I don't care.
Up to you.
SPEAKER: OK.
Let's start with the bad first.
CHRISTINE LAGORIO-CHAFKIN:
All right.
SPEAKER: And then, we
will be a little bit more
uplifting after.
I think the doxing, which
is sharing someone's
personal information online--
and I think the
moment that it really
highlights in the book is with
the Boston Bombing suspects.
So what was it like looking
back on that national, almost
global history moment, and how
Reddit's played a huge part
in it?
CHRISTINE LAGORIO-CHAFKIN: Yeah.
When the Boston
Marathon happened,
I was actually
working at CBS News.
I was a writer for Katie Couric.
And so if you're
in a newsroom, you
sit with a computer
in front of you
and a row of TVs
above your head.
And I sat there just
watching everything.
And we were reporting
on it simultaneously,
as everyone else was.
And this was, I think, America's
introduction to Reddit.
This was the time our parents
first heard about the site
because it was actually
a bunch of reporters
who were tweeting
stuff from Reddit
and spreading around little
bits of misinformation
that they didn't
know were unreliable
that fed, that kind of fed the
beast and fed that hype cycle.
And the news moved
so fast that--
it was a tricky thing
because Reddit had actually
solved crimes in the past.
It's the place where
you go if you get hit.
If your vehicle's parked
and gets hit and run,
and you've got a little
piece of the tail light
of the other car, someone
out there on Reddit
will identify that.
And you can give that to
your police department.
That's happened so many times.
So when it came to this higher
stakes situation with Boston,
it was just horrifying to think
of that family that was hurt.
I'm not sure if you
guys all know the story.
But basically, a suspect
was misidentified.
And it was a student named
Sunil who had disappeared
from his university.
He looked--
physically, just kind
of resembled one of the actual
suspects, the actual brothers.
And by the time--
his family was harassed.
And they were already
in a place of mourning
for having their son
having disappeared.
His body was later found
floating in a river
and in an unrelated death.
So it was just this
horrifying thing
that Reddit sort of happened
to-- because of the nature
of that community and being able
to post anything anonymously,
I think people got really
worked up about it.
And I think the incident
really highlights
how difficult it is
to be a moderator
in a situation like that.
Those moderators
were volunteers.
They were-- by my
best estimation,
I think a couple
of them were really
young students themselves.
Trying to keep up with
those instances of doxing
and whatnot, it's
almost impossible
when people jump
on it so quickly.
And I think it
raises the question,
how do we do content
management and community
management in this modern era?
How do you manage that
kind of bandwidth?
Facebook has had this
question repeatedly.
Twitter, obviously,
is grappling with it.
And Reddit has a fraction of the
employees as those companies.
It only has 400 and some.
Is that weight all on
the volunteer moderators?
SPEAKER: Well, I think
that's the other part
of the social, maybe,
bad is when there's
borderline illegal
or sometimes illegal
subreddits that have popped
up over the years that
can be started and how
moderators have to police that.
And I know there's
an interesting part
of the book of where they
had to almost make a decision
and draw a bright line.
And can you speak to--
CHRISTINE LAGORIO-CHAFKIN: Yeah.
Which decision was it
that you're talking about?
SPEAKER: I believe it was
with the jailbait and some
of those other--
CHRISTINE LAGORIO-CHAFKIN:
Well, is it
the first decision that Ellen
Pao made when she was-- yes.
There we go.
So after Yishan Wong left--
by the way, that's one
of my favorite lines
in the book is that--
and it's a direct
quote from Yishan--
that his story of
leaving the company
was unbelievable
because it's so weird.
And after he left,
Ellen Pao became CEO.
And she was already deep in
her "Kleiner Perkins" trial.
She was set to testify while
she was at Reddit, and she did.
And I think that
informed her a little bit
in terms of where we need to
start drawing lines online.
And I mean, it's always been
a tricky issue for Reddit
because it's always been known
as a haven for free speech.
And to say, no, we are
not, we are cutting off
these noxious communities, was
a really, really tricky thing.
So she basically tasked
her head community manager
with identifying
five subreddits--
say, OK, we're just
going to cut them off.
And one of them, most
notably, was fatpeoplehate.
That was a very
sizable community.
And so on that
day, they actually
did just make an announcement,
cut off the communities,
managed those same
communities popping
back up under new names--
fatpeoplehate2,
wedislikefatpeople,
or whatever.
It wasn't super savvy, but
of course, people tried.
After they cut off the next
waves, then they did see--
and this was not until years
later that we could really
document it-- but
researchers have
found that the simple act
of cutting off those five
first subreddits has improved
the quality of speech
on Reddit throughout the site.
You think of all this uncivil,
dis-civil discourse that's
been plaguing the
internet right now,
it actually demonstrably
improved that
throughout the site.
So years later-- and this wasn't
until I think a year or two ago
that this research came out--
it's shown that Ellen Pao did
accomplish what she set out to,
despite the crazy
backlash to it.
SPEAKER: So let's switch
gears to something good--
the Reddit Gifts, which
is its own business.
But I think the most recent stat
I saw was at the 10-year mark,
it was $29 million
worth of gifts.
How did that kind of--
again, the social impact
of that culture that was
self-created and then
turned into its own business
as a piece of the company.
CHRISTINE
LAGORIO-CHAFKIN: Totally.
SPEAKER: And it's got its own
really interesting history
being in a separate location
and all those different pieces.
CHRISTINE LAGORIO-CHAFKIN: Yeah.
So Reddit Gifts was actually
not created as part of Reddit
at all.
It was created by this guy named
Dan McComas out of his home
with his wife.
And eventually, it became
such a load for him
to bear that he went
to Reddit and said,
I can't do this anymore.
And somehow, miraculously, they
convinced Condé Nast to also--
Reddit to acquire Reddit Gifts.
And this just shows how crazy
and convoluted everything was.
But I don't know why--
I mean, I do slightly, but
it's kind of a long story--
Reddit Gifts was
not allowed even
in the office to work with
Reddit after it was acquired.
They were kept at a distance.
That sort of flipped
at one moment in time
when Yishan recognized--
I think Yishan and Ellen
together recognized--
hey, this part of the
business could make money.
They started
suggesting gifts to buy
and advertising on the market.
They created a
marketplace for gifts
and actually started
to make money.
By that time, Dan
and his wife had
moved to Salt Lake City,
because they were so
starved of resources
that they couldn't
afford to live in San Francisco
anymore, which is crazy.
I mean, I know it's an
expensive city, but--
so they're working in
a $300-a-month rented,
little tiny space near a Dunkin'
Donuts where they're hearing
the drive-thru
voice all day long.
And they start to manage to
make money for Reddit-- one
of the first times Reddit has
had significant actual income.
But yeah, Reddit Gifts-- it's
like this very uplifting story
of individuals
creating what I call
the daisy chain of goodwill.
You send a gift anonymously
to someone that you're given.
You can kind of stalk
their social presence.
You can check out
what they might like.
And then that person, who's
also signed up for gifts,
sends a gift to someone else.
And yeah, it's massive.
It's massive.
SPEAKER: Another kind
of fun social one
is the Ask Me Anything
subreddit that's obviously
a really big piece of the site.
I think-- are you going
to be doing one, correct?
CHRISTINE LAGORIO-CHAFKIN: Yes.
I'm going to do one on the 11th.
You guys should--
SPEAKER: I mean, that
also has its own issue.
It was run by one person.
And then there was
someone working full time
bringing celebrities on
and bringing guests on.
And now kind of just
spawned to what it is today.
But the social good that has
come from that subreddit--
can you speak a
little towards that?
CHRISTINE
LAGORIO-CHAFKIN: Right.
I guess I feel like AMA is just
Reddit's brightest, shiniest,
most celebrity-centric thing.
It's a lot of people's
gateway to Reddit, itself.
And I just, I love that every
scientist, and everybody
studying something super
niche, everyone who's
had a bizarre medical condition
or strange life coincidence
can just get on
Reddit and say, AMA,
I had a bellybutton transplant.
[LAUGHS] And over the years,
everyone from President Obama
to--
I don't know.
Who's the craziest?
What's your favorite AMA?
SPEAKER: I thought the Obama
was really interesting.
CHRISTINE LAGORIO-CHAFKIN: Yeah.
SPEAKER: And some of
the bizarre medical ones
are really, really
interesting to read.
CHRISTINE
LAGORIO-CHAFKIN: Right?
SPEAKER: But yeah, I mean, it's
just a rabbit hole to go down.
CHRISTINE LAGORIO-CHAFKIN: Yeah.
I love that the vacuum repairman
was the most popular AMA
for so long.
Because people just google
what's this valve in my vacuum?
And they come up with
the vacuum repairman
and can't take their
eyes away from it.
SPEAKER: So let's pivot about
some more where they are today.
So there's obviously a big
piece about the redesign
of the site and the app and also
just the adding ads and just
kind of all the different
pieces of the business now.
How did you take
where they are today,
where do you think
they're going,
and especially the
redesign piece, which
was a pretty big shift
for the business.
CHRISTINE LAGORIO-CHAFKIN: Yeah.
So when I started
reporting on the book,
Reddit had 20 employees, maybe.
And they were spread out
over different cities.
And so seeing, in
the last three years,
Reddit become a
legitimate big business,
like a legitimate
Silicon Valley,
fast-growing company valued
at more than $1 billion
has been super fascinating.
I watched them switch offices.
They're now at this big cool
office at 420 Taylor Street.
And I mean, despite that it's
kind of in the Tenderloin,
it's a pretty nice office.
[LAUGHS] And Reddit was--
I think even two years
ago-- even one year ago,
really-- it looked like 2005
had invaded your desktop when
you went to Reddit.com.
My favorite quote about
the way Reddit looks
was from "Bloomberg
Business Week."
They said it had all the
aesthetic seduction of a phone
book.
So dystopian Craigslist is
my other favorite description
of what Reddit looks like.
But within the
last year, they've
undergone a site redesign
that's really kind of complete.
It's taken every page and
turned it into something that--
when I was at South by
Southwest this last year
with Steve Huffman, on the
main stage, I asked him--
I was joking with him
about the redesign.
And I asked him
what it was going
to look like when it was done
because it wasn't done yet.
He said, oh, it'll look
just like Facebook.
Half the audience laughed.
And then, there was kind
of a pause, like, really?
And now, it honestly, it does.
It's white and blue and movable
blocks of text and images.
And you use the app.
You see that it's a lot
of big squares of memes
and photographs and videos,
like, infinite scroll, super
fast scroll.
So it's a new sort
of Reddit now.
And with that
redesign, they would
like to retain some of
that original anarchist
spirit of Reddit.
They want to retain some of that
Aaron Swartziness of it, right?
That I-- that rebel feeling.
And so even during
the redesign, they
brought in a bunch of staff
from Microsoft and from--
where else did they
hire designers from?
I forget the-- from big
companies basically-- people
who had done big tech
company designs before.
And when Steve
Huffman was presented
with some of their
mock-ups for the new site,
even he would bristle.
He created that
original ugly Reddit.
And redditors
themselves are very used
to this really tight design
where the site is cluttered,
and it's kind of ugly, and
they loved it for that.
So it was a difficult process
just like any tech site
redesign.
But Steve actually would
tell them sometimes,
can you just remove some
of that white space?
Or can you just chisel that
around the edges a little bit?
It looks too nice.
So it's a work in progress.
And as a company, they're
retaining the ability for users
still to revert
to the old design
so as to not alienate
users too, too much.
But that said, this
Reddit today is
trying to move into the future.
It would like to be--
to have its users be a little
less anonymous, I think.
You have the ability now
to create a profile page.
And on that profile
page, other users
can see the top five
subreddits you visit.
So there's a little
less anonymity,
even when you're hiding
behind a username.
So Reddit's opened up
the door for brands
to post, for media
companies to kind of get
involved more overtly.
They would love for every
celebrity to have an account
and be super public.
They would love for Elon Musk to
be not just tweeting or posting
his rocket videos on Instagram.
They would love for
that content to come
to Reddit first and then
spread out over the web.
So for Reddit to turn into more
than just kind of a melting pot
for the stuff of the internet
and a virality engine,
they want to be the
originator of that content.
And so that's what
we will be watching
over the next few years I think.
SPEAKER: So your
book, obviously,
is probably a to-be-continued
because there's obviously
an ending.
CHRISTINE LAGORIO-CHAFKIN: Yeah.
As if I haven't been working
on it long enough, right?
SPEAKER: What's the one
thing that didn't make it
into the book that you wish--
CHRISTINE LAGORIO-CHAFKIN:
There's a million things.
I know way too much
about all of these guys.
But there were some--
I mean, there's such
great cultural stuff
that happens on Reddit.
All the April Fools Day--
those little pranks.
And I mean, they're
not even pranks now.
They're full-blown
internet stunts.
You remember Place,
where anyone could
put any pixel on a canvas?
And it was through this
cringe moment on the internet
where everyone is
like, is it going
to be just swastikas
and penises?
Or is it going to be
a beautiful canvas
full of interesting thoughts
and different communities
coming together?
And we got to see sort of,
again, a mirror of the internet
happen.
I had this very long scene about
that that nobody wants to read,
I'm sure.
And same with the button.
I loved the button.
I don't know if you-- do
you remember that one?
No?
SPEAKER: I do want to open
it up to audience questions
because I know we have
lot of people in here.
So a lot of people line up.
I will do a few
rapid fire real quick
while people are lining up.
Favorite Reddit
scandal you covered?
CHRISTINE LAGORIO-CHAFKIN:
Favorite scandal?
Gosh, I didn't like any of them.
I mean, I did.
But they're all traumatizing
in their own way, right?
I mean, I think I did
some great reporting
around what's called amageddon.
You guys may remember
when an employee named
Victoria Taylor was sort of
unceremoniously dismissed
from her role.
And the internet snuffed out.
Well, Reddit snuffed out.
That was a great revolt of
moderators against the site
that they created
and that harbored
them and a fascinating moment.
And I think it's one
of those things that's
a few years in the
past, but I sort of
figured out what
actually happened,
what actually transpired there.
So I guess that was kind of fun.
SPEAKER: Favorite subreddit?
CHRISTINE LAGORIO-CHAFKIN:
My gateway subreddit when I
started reporting
was definitely--
well, there are a couple.
I think showerthoughts
and mildlyinteresting
was my gateway.
I just love the dumb photos
of, like, my gummy bear
has two heads.
SPEAKER: Favorite AMA guest?
CHRISTINE LAGORIO-CHAFKIN:
I don't know.
I love-- I mean,
Bill Nye, right?
Like, he used to be so good.
Now he's not as great.
But I don't know.
There are so many good ones.
Any time "The X-files" were--
they did so many repeatedly
good ones with Victoria.
That was always great.
SPEAKER: And last one.
Sort by new or sort by popular?
CHRISTINE LAGORIO-CHAFKIN:
I mix it up.
It depends what I'm
looking for, right?
You're always looking
for the best--
if you're a lurker,
you're looking
to get the best of
history of a certain time.
So yeah.
SPEAKER: A lot of questions.
CHRISTINE LAGORIO-CHAFKIN:
Yeah, great.
SPEAKER: So we'll
start over here.
AUDIENCE: Reddit's not
entirely original, right?
We've had Slashdot, where
you could upvote comments.
We've had 4chan, which
has also produced
a considerable amount
of viral content
and also is full of
terrible content.
So why did Reddit succeed where
others before it had failed?
CHRISTINE LAGORIO-CHAFKIN: Yeah.
Well, so Reddit was actually
designed after the Delicious
Popular page.
I don't know if you know that.
It was sort of just a clone
of that, which is crazy
because Delicious
didn't even make it
in a substantial way as its
original vision, at least.
But I mean, Reddit was sort
of the best of all the worlds.
And sadly, 4chan was
started by Chris Poole.
He just couldn't-- he was
one guy working on it alone.
He couldn't really sustain that.
And it really spiraled way
the heck out of his control.
So I mean, it was never
really a company either.
He just didn't want it
to be, so that's fine.
Reddit had enough
of a company to it.
It had enough of a
backbone and just
such a great community of
moderators through the years.
I don't know.
I mean, it's amazing
that it made it, right?
There's so many times during
the book where, as a reader--
well, working on it, but
also reading it-- it's
like, how did it
possibly come through?
And that's one of
the main reactions
I'm getting to the book from
readers, which is why I stated
that answer in that weird way.
It's like, how did
it make it through?
But yeah, by a hair it did.
And there are still really,
really substantial challenges
I think that it faces.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CHRISTINE LAGORIO-CHAFKIN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
the redesign--
very interesting stuff.
So I want to say
about a month ago,
there was a post
on DataIsBeautiful.
Obviously, there is
some response bias here.
But it was a survey about use
of old.reddit versus www.reddit.
And about 80% of responders
said they still use old.reddit.
CHRISTINE
LAGORIO-CHAFKIN: Really?
Yeah, that doesn't surprise me.
AUDIENCE: So it
doesn't surprise you.
And you've spoken
to these people.
Why are they so confident
in it if 80% of responders
say they still use
the old version?
CHRISTINE
LAGORIO-CHAFKIN: I mean,
they're confident in
their own work, right?
I mean, they work there.
Yeah, at one point
when I was interviewing
Steve Huffman on stage, he--
I think we were--
I don't know what
I was talking--
it may have been a design thing.
And I was speaking kind
of critically of it.
And he said, well, hey,
come on, I work there.
And they believe that they
need to move into the future.
I think they've seen Reddit
kind of left in the dust
by the rest of the
internet in terms of design
amongst other things.
Content was obviously
another area
where they were
slow to act and slow
to put into policy certain
behaviors that they needed to.
So the redesign-- I
think it's simply--
Steve has a mandate
from his board
to get to 1 billion users.
And I don't think he believed--
I'm not sure.
I don't mean to put words into
his mouth-- but he and his team
didn't believe they
could do it looking
like 2005 on your browser.
AUDIENCE: Do you think the
2005 option will remain,
even if it's not the default?
CHRISTINE LAGORIO-CHAFKIN:
Oh, interesting.
I know.
I know everyone wants
to know that, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, well, you have
a lot of insider information,
right?
CHRISTINE
LAGORIO-CHAFKIN: I don't
have that inside information.
I will ask next time
I talk with them.
Because--
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
I will reiterate the
question on the AMA.
CHRISTINE LAGORIO-CHAFKIN:
Thank you.
We should.
And we can get spez
to comment, right?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: A lot
of the stories you
told seemed to illustrate some
of the moral hazards associated
with this really anarchic
internet presence.
And I thought that the story
you told about Ellen Pao
was interesting because it says
that, actually, the leadership
of these sites can have a really
big influence on the kinds
of communities that develop.
And the leadership of other
large social media sites
have sometimes had great
influences on their communities
and sometimes bad ones.
And so I'm curious,
how seriously
does the leadership
of Reddit right now
take the extent to which Reddit
has been involved in fostering
a modern, violently
misogynistic, white supremacist
movement, which has largely
developed in the shadows
of Reddit and other places too.
CHRISTINE LAGORIO-CHAFKIN: This
is a huge question on my mind
too.
And I've tried to get down
to it through my reporting
over the years.
They will address it with
me, and we do talk about it.
And I do think that
they have been--
they jumped on it
the obvious alt-right
subreddits fairly quickly.
I mean, the stuff was
there, and it was brewing.
But obviously,
The_Donald is just
this huge question for them.
It's got more than
600,000 subscribers now
and still harbors in it's
network of adjacent communities
a lot of the worst stuff, like,
the worst speech we see online.
And it's so tricky.
I think that Steve still
believes that they have
a right to political speech.
And now that we are in an era
where the things that the First
Amendment was meant to protect,
namely, political speech
is at times intersecting with or
the same thing as hate speech.
These sites and
their leaders need
to address that and draw, I
think, draw firmer lines on it.
I think that it's a huge
question for regulators
and for our government
as well, despite that
that's a tricky thing
that, in the business,
you don't really want--
you don't know whether
you want to be regulated.
It's something
that I think people
need to speak to
their representatives
about if they feel strongly
about it because it is not
happening at the pace that
speech is evolving online,
whatever way you
feel about regulation
versus a business handling
this stuff on their own.
But yeah, it's a
huge, huge issue.
And it's still there, right?
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
This is really interesting
to hear about the business
history of Reddit.
So I think on subreddits
that aren't explicitly
female-oriented, there's
often an implicit assumption
that you're male.
And comments can be
kind of quick to jump
to sexist or objectification
or something.
CHRISTINE LAGORIO-CHAFKIN:
Yeah, absolutely.
AUDIENCE: Was there
any discussion
inside about either making
the culture, by default,
more neutral or
more female-friendly
or any sort of consciousness
internally about that?
CHRISTINE LAGORIO-CHAFKIN: Yes.
There is a great
consciousness internally
that I've seen about it.
I-- again, it's an
uphill battle for them.
But still, I think 60% or more
of redditors are male, 65%,
I think.
And you can tell, right?
When you're-- even still.
They've made a great effort
to reduce casual misogyny
on the site.
And I think, for me,
I can look back now--
years ago, and I think it was
maybe five or more years ago--
the culture on the
site was so much worse
than it is now, that a
business manager of Reddit
in a casual press interview
encouraged all women
to completely stay away from
r/gaming because it was simply
too abusive.
I mean, can you imagine that?
And today, even on
TwoXChromosomes,
you can get harassed
for being a woman.
It's crazy.
I just saw, a
couple of weeks ago,
a woman posted something about--
she was having a
really bad week.
And then she scrappily
looked at a YouTube video
and fixed her parents' dryer
that was broken on her own--
went out and bought the part.
And then you just have
people bashing her saying,
why would a woman even
try to do such a thing
and questioning her abilities.
And the way Reddit is
set up with moderators--
volunteers being responsible for
keeping all of that content how
they see fit in their
little box of Reddit,
it's so tricky to regulate
anything that's not strictly
hate speech.
And they're still
drawing new lines.
So much the way we talk
online exists in a gray area.
And I don't know--
even personally, I question--
I used to-- I was educated as a
journalist and really used to--
part of the foundation
of that was I
believe people should have
the information they want.
And people should be able
to speak how they want.
And now, again, that hate
speech can be synonymous
with political speech or
with a casual statement,
how do we go forward?
Do you-- I don't know.
Feel free to ask a
follow up question
or say what you think
about it because I
think it's really complicated.
AUDIENCE: I think even
if 65% is a majority,
it's actually not a
very big majority.
And I think I had
seen a statistic
about how it's really not
as skewed as people perceive
it to be.
So I sort of wish that they
would publicize more that--
so you really don't
need to assume.
CHRISTINE LAGORIO-CHAFKIN:
I have it.
65-- this is brand new--
65% percent male.
35% female.
By age, majority of our
audience is under 34.
A quarter of the
audience under 24.
AUDIENCE: First off, I just want
to thank you for being here.
CHRISTINE LAGORIO-CHAFKIN:
Thank you for being here too.
AUDIENCE: It's been
definitely really interesting.
So you talked about the horrible
doxing and misidentification
that happened with
the Boston Bombing.
And then you look
at something like--
for those of you who
don't know, there
was a mass shooting
in Jacksonville
at a "Madden" tournament.
And there's a really
big overlap in those two
communities with Reddit
and gamers and all of that.
So there was a really big
subreddit-- a few of them--
that popped up
around that trying
to almost do the same thing.
And those got shut down very
quickly by internal moderators.
But you said they're
all volunteers.
CHRISTINE
LAGORIO-CHAFKIN: Admins
are the-- there's an internal
community team, which
is more substantial
today than ever,
but I would say
shockingly small.
AUDIENCE: Well, that actually
really was my question.
What do you know about that
internal community team,
if you can share anything
about it, about its growth
and about the strategies
around that and ways
that those things are being
handled post-Boston Marathon.
CHRISTINE LAGORIO-CHAFKIN:
Yeah, yeah.
I don't know exactly
how big it is today.
But more than a year ago, I sat
in on a meeting with about 12
of the community
team members and got
to know them and their jobs.
And they each have
a purview, right?
There's one who works
on r/books and r/AMA.
And there are two who
manage the most passionate
political speech.
They are the most
familiar with The_Donald.
I have quite a bit of their
storyline in the book.
You should check that out.
Their names are, adorably,
Bill and [? Susie. ?]
And they each have
really crazy stories
of how they came to Reddit and
came to work together also.
And it's a team that's evolving.
And it's a team that
is very tight-knit.
And they work hard together.
They have-- so you think
of this community, right?
They are, like, good cop, right?
They're working-- they're
communicating with their user
names.
They're well-known people
if you're a real redditor.
And say, there's a couple dozen.
I don't know exact
number, whatever.
But then you've got a
team that's, sort of,
their secret counterpart.
That's called-- well, there's
two parts of it, actually.
But the secret counterpart,
literally, their identities
are not public.
They are not known as
employees of Reddit.
And they are the ones that enact
bans and cut off communities
and identify communities
for being cut off.
And there's just as
many of them on staff,
which is really fascinating.
And then they've got a data
side of that team that's
just evolving now.
That's what you saw last week.
Steve was referencing in
his public comments about,
how are we going to manage
the flow of disinformation
in the future from Russians?
That's the team that
he's talking about.
They also, by the
way-- you might
be fascinated-- kind of
think of Russian influence
on the site, or
any disinformation
campaign-spreading, as
just the same as bots.
If you can take it down from
the side of it being spam,
that's ideal for them.
So then part of
this team is called
anti-evil, which is a
great team name, of course.
And they are the ones that are
secret and doing this stuff.
You can think of them
as sort of bad cop.
And then their
counterparts are--
or actually, trust and safety
is kind of the secret one.
And then you've got anti-evil.
And they're kind of Robocop.
They build the algorithms.
They bust the spam.
So you think, good
cop, bad cop, Robocop--
not my original line, but
it's a great way of thinking
about how they're structured.
AUDIENCE: As Reddit's
gotten more popular,
it seems that there's
a very obvious play
towards a more valuable
demographic for advertising
and product promotion.
And it seems that there's a
pretty obvious correlation
for AstroTurf-type
submitted content,
whether that's a
company promoting
a product or some content
that they've created
or something to political
ends of a similar nature.
Has there been any efforts
or any ongoing work
towards making sure
that it's actually
people behind this instead
of companies and shadow
organizations?
CHRISTINE LAGORIO-CHAFKIN:
Yeah, yeah.
I think, in comparison, in
contrast to what it could be,
Reddit is incredibly good at
managing spam and that sort
of posting by brands and stuff.
That's got dual components.
It's the community
regulating itself, right?
People hate seeing that
kind of disingenuous,
"I'm just self-promoting"
kind of thing
and will report that
on Reddit right away.
And also the teams are
very good at managing bots.
So yeah, I mean, will
we see a little bit
more promotional content?
I don't know.
Yeah, but this is stealing
a line from Steve Huffman.
Like, you have to
be pretty naive
if you think no one is
marketing to you already, right?
They are.
They're just trying to
do it in more savvy ways
than they maybe could.
I don't know.
I think that we will see
more brands actually come
to the Reddit way of
doing things and being
a little more genuine maybe.
If they can just go on
and say, like, hey, want
some free stuff?
Look at this AMA.
We'll give out 10 free books.
Or we'll give the best person
with the answer to this trivia
question a free shaving kit.
I don't know.
I mean, there's a million ways
to actually market on Reddit
that aren't gross.
So I think brands will
come around to that.
And their ads don't look
bad under new Reddit.
So I don't know.
What do you think?
Do you think-- are you seeing
more bleh-feeling stuff?
AUDIENCE: I mean, less the
actual advertising that's
on there.
I understand that's part
of the business model.
And more, I guess, accounts
that are pretending
to be people that are upvoted en
masse and kind of artificially
floating towards the top of
the front page that are not
just something that
somebody found interesting
and thought it was
relevant and more placed
there for a very specific goal,
whether that's site traffic,
selling products, et cetera.
CHRISTINE
LAGORIO-CHAFKIN: Got it.
I mean, they're pretty
good at cracking down
on nets of individuals
who upvote stuff.
That said, even
certain Russian domains
can get past those filters.
So I don't know.
I think, honestly, that's
been a strength in the past.
And maybe it still happens.
But I think that is far less
of a concern for me personally
or many citizens of
the United States
than, say, Iranian or Russian
influence on the election.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SPEAKER: Christine,
thank you for being here.
CHRISTINE LAGORIO-CHAFKIN:
Thank you.
SPEAKER: Appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]